plusieurs pays européens comme
l'Allemagne ou la Belgique l'ont déjà
interdit la pêche est dans le viseur du
gouvernement la pub cette cigarette
électronique jetable qui selon la
première ministre Elisabeth borde
donnerait de mauvaises habitudes aux
jeunes c'est-à-dire les incitants à
aller vers le tabagisme on rappelle que
75000 français meurent chaque année de
ce fléau résultat la poste pourrait être
interdite dès l'an prochain et ça fait
réagir comme vous allez le voir dans ce
reportage à Tours d'Aurélie Renaud
un petit bâtonnet plastique une pile au
lithium et du liquide avec ou sans
nicotine la peur comprend entre 300 et
600 bouffées un produit jetable qui
représente environ 15% du chiffre
d'affaires des buralistes en France une
cigarette électronique interdite aux
mineurs comme la cigarette ils essaient
toujours voilà on leur demande leur
carte d'identité s'ils n'ont pas on
refusait à vendre mais bon ils vont
ailleurs
dans la rue nous rencontrons cet élève
de seconde il a 16 ans il utilise la
puce depuis peu ça fait trois mois
quatre mois vous n'avez jamais
tu payes on vous demande pas votre pièce
d'identité
alors que le tabagisme chez les 15-25
ans avait baissé depuis 2017 il repart à
la hausse avec la puce chez les très
jeunes une donnée qui inquiète la Ligue
contre le cancer la peur serait trop
incitative quand on intervient dans les
collèges pour eux le goût le fait que ça
soit un produit qui soit coloré qui soit
vraiment mis en avant sur les réseaux
sociaux il voit plus ça comme un bonbon
et même il y en a beaucoup qui nous
disent oh bah la plupart des puffs il
n'y a pas de nicotine un nouveau plan
national de lutte contre le tabagisme
devrait interdire les cigarettes
électroniques jetables la première
ministre parle d'une mauvaise habitude
donnée aux jeunes je sais que j'ai des
amis elles peuvent ça les a aidés à
arrêter de vraiment fumer le tabac le
vrai tabac et donc moi je pense que
c'est un peu ridicule de l'arrêter mais
après c'est pas bien tout le monde les
jette partout ça donc vaut mieux une
clope électronique l'idée c'est que ce
soit un accompagnement vers un arrêt ou
une diminution pas un remplacement ou un
nouvel objet de dépense les pubs se
retrouvent dans le collimateur d'autres
pays c'est le cas de la Belgique de
l'Allemagne et de l'Irlande